todo lo que hemos visto hasta el momento
ha sido influidos estacionarios o
estáticos ya que queremos aprender cómo
se comportaba todo al estar estático por
lo que ahora vamos a ver qué le sucede
cuando los fluidos están en movimiento
imaginemos que tenemos un tubo que tiene
una entrada más o menos así y se va a ir
ampliando
un poco de manera que el extremo de la
izquierda
va a ser menor que el extremo de la
derecha y también vamos a imaginarnos
que este tubo está lleno de algún fluido
algún líquido no necesariamente agua
vamos a llamar al área que se encuentra
en este extremo área de entrada
y es la abertura que lleva a la entrada
del tubo y el área que se encuentra a la
salida del tubo la vamos a llamar a 0
ahora pensemos qué pasaría en este
líquido si se estuviera moviendo digamos
que se mueve hacia el tubo más o menos
así y va entrando con una velocidad de
iu
pensemos en que tanto volumen se mueve
dentro del tubo después de t segundos
después de t segundos si vemos que
tenemos esta área y lo que esté aquí se
va a mover hacia la derecha a qué
distancia se va a mover en ese tiempo
bueno recordemos nuestra fórmula básica
de de distancia es igual a la rapidez
por el tiempo
la distancia que algo viaja es de igual
a velocidad por el tiempo por lo que
después de tres segundos cualquier
fluido que estaba a la entrada dentro
dentro del área y ahora viajado o se
habrá movido que tanto hacia la derecha
y vamos a asumir que el tubo no cambia
demasiado su forma al menos en este
tramo de aquí
este tramo
a más o menos de acá
no cambia mucho el tubo en este segmento
y nuestra pregunta es bueno que tanto se
ha desplazado en esta parte en esta
sección pues bueno se habrá desplazado
velocidad de entrada por el lapso de
tiempo
que puede ser en metros o en centímetros
o cualquier unidad de distancia así que
después de tres segundos esencialmente
esta cantidad de agua se habrá
desplazado dentro del tubo y se pueden
imaginar esto como un cilindro de
líquido y nuevamente les comento que
estamos asumiendo que de aquí a acá en
el tubo no cambia mucho sus dimensiones
cuál es el volumen de este cilindro de
agua el volumen de entrada de
y volumen de entrada va a ser igual
durante esos segundos va a ser igual al
área de entrada que es esta de aquí
en el área de entrada y por la longitud
que la velocidad del fluido por el
tiempo
te hago la distinción este el volumen
voy a ponerlo como una d mayúscula
volumen y esta vez de aquí es velocidad
y esta va a ser la cantidad de volumen
que entra por el tubo a la entrada al
tubo recordemos la definición del
líquido que vimos hace varios vídeos que
es un fluido que no puede comprimirse no
es que todo el líquido se quede en un
lado y nada salga del otro el mismo
volumen de fluido tendrá que salir del
tubo por lo que esto debe ser igual al
volumen de salida eso que acabamos de
dibujar
o describir va a ser igual a mi volumen
de salida mi volumen de salida va para
acá
d mayúscula 0 porque estamos hablando de
volúmenes
y algo que estamos asumiendo en esta
fracción del tubo que estamos analizando
es que tampoco hay fricción en este
fluido no es turbulento y tampoco es
viscoso un fluido viscoso es un líquido
con mucha fricción en sí mismo y no es
algo que naturalmente se mueva haciendo
asistencia
algo no es viscoso no tiene resistencia
consigo mismo y se mueve libremente y
sin turbulencia
lo llamamos fluido láminas
fluido
láminas
lindas
qué es algo bueno de saber que es lo
opuesto a un fluido viscoso
frente líquidos tienen diferentes
niveles de viscosidad y más adelante
hablaremos más al respecto
por ejemplo el jarabe y la mantequilla
de cacahuate tienen un alto nivel de
viscosidad incluso el vidrio que se
considera un fluido con una viscosidad
muy muy grande a diferencia de algunos
compuestos en campos magnéticos que se
comportan como un fluido laminar
perfecto en esas circunstancias el
volumen de entrada de un fluido que no
se puede comprimir tiene que ser igual
al volumen de salida del mismo fluido y
cuál será este volumen de salida
bueno pues de manera similar vamos a
remarcar en esta parte del cilindro
el área de salida
que es a 0 y después de tres segundos
cuál será la cantidad de agua o de
líquido que haya salido bueno cualquier
cantidad de líquido que estaba aquí en
esta parte al inicio de nuestro periodo
de tiempo ahora estará a cierta
distancia a la salida más o menos
imaginemos una distancia
a la salida
esa es la cantidad del volumen
desplazado podemos imaginar un cilindro
aquí afuera y en este caso el ancho del
cilindro este de acá
este ancho base la distancia recorrida
por esta por este líquido al salir que
va a ser de igual manera mi velocidad de
salida
velocidad de salida
post
mi lapso de tiempo de recordemos de
minúscula es velocidad de mayúscula va a
ser volumen
así que este volumen de salida va a ser
igual a mi velocidad de salida
por el tiempo
y multiplicado por el área de salida qué
es
es mi volumen de salida
y nuevamente les mencionó que en este
lapso de tiempo t el volumen de entrada
tiene que ser igual al volumen de salida
aquí escribo mi volumen de entrada tiene
que ser igual a mi volumen de salida
por lo tanto puedo sustituir esto como
por d
porque va a ser igual
o por de o porte y podemos simplificar
esto ya que en ambos lados de la
ecuación tengo a te lo puedo quitar de
manera que me quedaría
área de entrada por velocidad de entrada
va a ser igual al área de salida por la
velocidad de salida y esta ecuación se
le llama en el movimiento de fluidos la
ecuación de continuidad y haremos
algunos problemas usando esto en algunos
momentos una cosa que quiero
presentarles ahora es cuál es el volumen
por segundo ya que es algo con lo que
vamos a trabajar en el siguiente vídeo
dijimos que entre segundos tenemos esta
cantidad de volumen entrando y en el
mismo lapso tendremos el mismo volumen a
la salida
cuál será el volumen por segundo pues es
el volumen de entrada lo escribimos acá
va a ser el volumen de entrada
entre el lapso de tiempo t
y a esto le llamamos flujo aprenderemos
más acerca del flujo en el futuro en
especial cuando vemos el cálculo
vectorial pero el flujo es que tanta
cantidad cruza una superficie en cierta
cantidad de tiempo que tanto volumen de
algo cruza cierta superficie
en nuestro caso es la superficie de
entrada del lado izquierdo cuánto
líquido lo cruzará en cierta cantidad de
tiempo y encontraremos que es el volumen
de entrada que lo cruza cada tres
segundos
y a esto le llamamos flujo
quizá hayan escuchado de el condensador
de flujo en volver al futuro y quizás
podamos imaginar a qué se refiere con
eso pero veamos si podemos usar el flujo
y esas ideas para llegar a otras
ecuaciones interesantes permítanme
limpiar la pantalla
así que sabemos que el volumen entre el
tiempo va a ser igual al flujo
y la variable que la gente usa para
referirse al flujo es
y sus unidades son metros cúbicos sobre
segundo también sabemos que el área de
entrada
por la velocidad de entrada
va a ser igual a la área de salida por
la velocidad de salida y esa es la
ecuación de continuidad que se cumple
siempre que se tiene un fluido laminar y
en el siguiente vídeo usaremos esta
información para encontrar cuál es la
potencia de un sistema donde tenemos
líquidos que pasan por tuberías nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo